CLOSE IRATE IT UP WE ARE GOING
TO GO GET AHEAD AND GET STARTED
BECAUSE I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL IS HERE SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE STARTING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ARE
FIRST.
BILL PRISONER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE TO
COME UP AND PRESENT.
A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE.
HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
SO AS YOU ARE AWARE. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED A VETERANS DESIGNATIONS
ON DRIVER'S LICENSES AND STATE
ID CARDS. AND SINCE THEN HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM. EYES HAD A AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE ACTUALLY
칩 NEARLY A THIRD OF THE PEOPLE
THAT APPLY FOR THAT DESIGNATION
FIND THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
VETERANS BENEFITS THAT THEY DID
NOT KNOW ABOUT. AND THAT IS LED
TO OVER THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND I IN RECEIPTS TO
THOSE VETERANS SO I JUST KIND OF
A A TOOL.
PURPOSE TO THAT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN A SUCCESSFUL IN THAT WAY.
.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PARTICIPATION
RATE IN THAT PROGRAM IS STILL
VERY LOW LESS THAN TEN PERCENT
OF VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
APPLIED FOR THIS DESIGNATION AND
PART OF THE REASON IS THAT
THERE'S A FEE ATTACHED TO. THE
DESIGNATION IT'S ONLY FIVE
DOLLARS BUT IT IS AN IMPEDIMENT.
SO LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
QUIRK SILVA AUTHORED LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD EXEMPT LOW INCOME ON
HOMELESS VETERANS FROM HAVING TO
PAY THAT FEE AND THIS BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE. BUILDS
ON THAT SUCCESS BY EXEMPTING
SENIOR CITIZENS WHO ARE ALSO
VETERANS FROM HAVING TO PAY THE
FEE SO THE HOPE IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO LEAD TO. A HIGHER
PARTICIPATION RATE AND AT THE
SAME TIME HELP THESE VETERANS
GET THE DESIGNATION AND THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY ARE VERY
ENTITLED TO.
VERY GOOD AND OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD HELP
WITH.
.
ATTRACTING VETERANS TO GET TO
CBS OFFICES.
AND FIND BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO.
OUR CLIENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS FACTIONS
COUNCIL IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU I THINK ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS AND SPARK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR DAHLE
I'M GONE HARPER WITH AMERICAN
LEGION DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA. WE
WERE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
LIVING IN THIS GREAT STATE. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
HOPE YOU'LL.
DO I VOTE ON IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
COLONEL LORNA GREECE
REPRESENTING MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
WITH CHAPTERS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ACTION AND LORRAINE PLASS WITH
AMERICAN VETERANS AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ALSO.
GOOD AFTERNOON EMPTYING GOTHAM
I'M THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
AS YOU KNOW WE ARE ONLY AND.
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT OF PERHAPS
HAVE SOME FINAL WORDS.
APARTMENT YOU HAVE ANY FINAL.
BUT WHEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME
COMES APPRECIATED AYE VOTE THIS
IS A VERY SMALL WAY OF SAYING
THANK YOU TO. ALL THE FOLKS WHO
GAVE SUCH A LARGE SACRIFICE TO
OUR COUNTRY AND I THINK IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE TO WAIVE THE
FEE UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND THEN AND
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS GOING
TO BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS SOON AS WE GET
A QUORUM THANK YOU MANAGER
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR JUST LET ME CHOI MIN
I THINK IT'S A. OF REALLY
FABULOUS IDEA THAT YOU'VE PUT
INTO THIS BILL AND A. VERY
WORTHWHILE AND ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'LL BE HAPPY TO MAKE THE
MOTION A TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
VENTURA ARE ALRIGHT.
WELL I AS YOU ARE NOT EXCUSE
YET.
MISTER FRAZIER.
EGGMAN INSURANCE ROUGHLY THEY
PRESENCE.
UP MISTER OBERNOLTE AS THE CHAIR
TRANSPORTATION YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ADDITION.
OF THE REMAINDER OF THE VETERAN
POPULATION DO.
THIS SAME FAVOR.
WHAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
I I IT IS UNITED CAST I AM IN
FULL AGREEMENT THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXEMPT EVERYONE
FROM HAVING TO PAY THIS FEE.
THE INDICATION THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT THAT WOULD ARE REDUCE OUR
CHANCES OF GETTING A PASSED.
I AND SO I'M WILLING TO ACCEPT
HALF A LOAF BUT WE'VE DONE THE
MATH AND OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF.
THE VETERANS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS DESIGNATION ARE ALSO
SIXTY TWO AN OVER SO THIS IS
LITERALLY HALF A LOAF THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO ACCEPT IT FOR
OVER. HALF OF THEM AND I WOULD
LOVE TO REVISIT THIS.
MAYBE NEXT YEAR WITH YOU AND.
AND AND MAYBE TRYING TO WAY
WITH THE FEE ALTOGETHER WELL AND
COULD YOU KNOW I'VE LEARNED THAT
MY COMMITTEE BASED ON THE.
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO NOW YOU'RE
SAYING NO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M NOT I
MIGHT PULL BACK INTO MY
COMMITTEE AND HOLD.
A BASED ON THAT THAT PROMISE
THAT YOU HAD MADE ME.
SO YOU KNOW AGAIN HERE I'VE
ANOTHER WHACK AT THE APPLE LATE
THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
GOING FORWARD.
YOU'VE MADE THE DECISION TO
CHANGE YOUR MIND BECAUSE OF.
THE ABILITY. THAT IT POSSIBLY WE
GET OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS BASED
ON THAT YOU MADE A COMMITMENT TO
ME. AS THE CHAIR.
AND SO.
.
I'M GONNA VOTE NO TODAY.
AND I URGE OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE
NO TODAY BASED ON THE CHAIRMAN
ALLOWING A BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE.
HUNTER PROMISE FROM A MEMBER AND
THEN NOT HOLDING UP. HIS END OF
THE BARGAIN.
TO TRY TO SAVE HIS BILL.
THAT BEING SAID.
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENT.
I WILL GIVE YOU A YES VOTE TODAY
NOT PULL BACK INTO MY COMMITTEE.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE.
.
MISS UNDERSTANDING THAT WAS
NEVER MY INTENTION TO BREAK A
PROMISE THAT I MADE YOU.
.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
TO COMMIT TO TAKING AMENDMENT
TO EXTENDED TO ALL VETERANS.
WITH THAT SAID ARE ALL EXPECT TO
SEE IT IN APPROPRIATIONS THE
AMENDMENTS MADE.
AND THEN RESERVE JUDGMENT ON THE
FLOOR AS I HAVE.
NOW WITH THAT I WILL SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR I'M DOING THAT BECAUSE.
I WOULD NEVER WANT TO GO BACK A
COMMITMENT THAT I MADE THAT
MATTERS A LOT MORE TO ME THAN A
YES OR A NO VOTE. UNDERSTAND AND
THAT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
AGREEMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE STILL DO NOT OH YES.
STIR VOEPEL NOT QUITE SURE WHAT
THAT WAS.
BUT I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO TELL
EVERYONE HERE THAT THIS IS A
VERY GOOD BILL.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS IS.
MANY OF US VETERANS RECEIVE
DISCOUNTS
ONE WE SHOW OUR VETERANS
DRIVER'S LICENSE WITH VETERANS
ON IT THAT'S OUR ID.
YOU GET TEN PERCENT OFF AT
LOWE'S YOU GET.
PERCENTS OFF AT HOME DEPOT.
VETERANS AT THE AIRPORT GET TEN
PERCENT OFF OF WHAT THEY
PURCHASE AT MOST PLACES
SO WE'RE TALKING OF A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TEN PERCENT FIFTEEN
PERCENT DISCOUNTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. VOLUNTARILY
GIVEN TO VETERANS IF.
YOU PRODUCE.
YOU'RE.
VETERAN.
DRIVERS LICENSE
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY.
VERY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY TO
HOMELESS VETERANS LOW INCOME
VETERANS VETERANS ON DISABILITY.
IF YOU'RE A HUNDRED PERCENT
DISABLED VETERAN YOU ONLY GET
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SOME CHANGE A MONTH THAT'S
BARELY ENOUGH TO LIVE ON.
SO THESE DISCOUNTS AND THIS ID
IS WORTH IT LITERALLY WORTH IT'S
WEIGHT IN GOLD. AND IT CAN
ACTUALLY HELP PUT AN
EXTERMINATOR FOOD ON THE TABLE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I AM SO GLAD HE TOOK THE
AMENDMENT.
SIR.
EVERY VETERAN SHOULD GET IT IN
YOUR EXACTLY SPOT ON. WELL
MISTER VOEPEL AND AGAIN I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I AM THE
AUTHOR OF AB NINE THIRTY FIVE
WHO IT. WHO ORIGINATED THE?
AFTER MANY MANY YEARS.
OF TRYING TO GET THE DESIGNATION
A DRIVER'S LICENSE WITH P.
COMEDY.
WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH THE DMV.
AND IT WAS DRASTICALLY REDUCED
FROM TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO FIVE
DOLLARS.
NOW FOR GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SOME KIND OF A DEAL IT SHOULD BE
FOR ALL VETERANS GOING CLOSE BUT
YOU DON'T JUST HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR.
VETERANS DESIGNATION TO GET THE
DISCOUNT YOU CAN UTILIZE YOUR DD
TWO FOURTEEN ALSO FOR
IDENTIFICATION TO GET THOSE
DISCOUNTS BUT. AGAIN AS A A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN WANTING TO SUPPORT. OUR
VETERANS
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHEN I WAS PART OF THE DEAL WAS
FIVE DOLLARS.
NOW IF IT'S GOING TO BE ZERO IT
HAS TO BE EQUITABLE FOR ALL
VETERANS.
TO.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO FIRST SAYS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD.
INTEGRAL.
IRWIN. HERE VOEPEL.
CH치VEZ.
DALY.
FRAZIER AYE.
GLORIA THIS OLD.
ATTENDANCE
MATHIS HERE HERE.
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
SALAS HA HA THAT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAD A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
UP WILL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER IT FOR ORIGINATING THE
BILL AS I WAS A ME TOO ON THE
BILL ADDING ANOTHER AMENDMENT TO
WIN THE US.
TO ADD HOMELESS VETS AND SO I
THINK WE ALL ARE THINKING ALIKE
HERE.
.
BUT ONE THING THAT I HAVE
BROUGHT UP I HAD ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMITTEES THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AGREED
WITH IS THAT.
AS WE MAKE LEGISLATION AND WE
ARE ABLE TO MOVE IT THROUGH AND
GET SIGNED. WE DON'T ALWAYS.
VERIFY IF IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED SO. I THINK YEAH
THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT I DID
ASK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF EGGMAN AND
THE CHAIR OF ACCOUNTABILITY OF
FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. ON HOW
THIS WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED IN
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE BUT I ALSO
HAD ANOTHER.
HOMELESS BILL FOR A FEE WAIVER
JUST FOR AN ID AND MANY OF THE
DMV'S OUT WHEN IT WAS AND
ACTUALLY SEE ANNABEL THERE
BECAUSE SHE. WAS A WILL.
ON OUR TEAM AT THAT POINT WE
FOUND THAT THEY WERE NOT
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING IT AND
TELL WE HAD TO MAKE QUITE A FUSS
AND SO THIS. AGAIN.
HOPING THAT IT GETS ALL THE WAY
TO THE GOVERNOR AND SIGN BUT
EVEN WITH THE TWO. OF BILLS THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE.
I THINK IT'S PART OF OUR JOB TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DIEM THESE
ARE ACTUALLY MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN
SIGNED BUT THANK YOU. PACKETS
OUT DID YOU OF THE COMMENTS
FRAZIER NO JUST.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE.
UNBELIEVABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
VETERANS TO COME IN IT TO THEIR
CV ESOS ALSO IF THE FIVE DOLLARS
WAS A RESTRICTION.
THIS WILL GIVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO COME IN
AND SEE IF THEY QUALIFY FOR
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS.
THROUGH THE FEDERAL OF GI BILL
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE AFFORDED TO THEM SO.
EXPANDING THIS IN IF THERE WERE
RESTRICTIONS AND WE HEARD SOME
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE FIVE
DOLLARS WAS WHO WAS IMPLEMENTED.
THIS WILL BE HAVE EVERYBODY THAT
SAME EQUAL FOOTING TO GO OUT AND
GET ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND I
APPRECIATE.
ALRIGHT SO I'M JUST TO BE CLEAR
IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE NOT TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT
DO YOU HAVE MADE.
YOUR COMMITMENT WITH MISTER
FRAZIER MOVING FORWARD THERE IS
A WE ARE VOTING RIGHT NOW ON THE
BILL WITHOUT.
ANY AMENDMENTS AND THE MOTION
IS.
A PERSON IN MOTION AND THE
SECOND.
CIRCUIT ALRIGHT AND SO THE
MOTION S TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND I.
PLEASE UPLOAD CULT. IRWIN.
AND I IRWIN AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL
AYE CH치VEZ.
DALY. DALY AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER
AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER AYE SOLACE.
AT SIX ZERO.
YEAH ALRIGHT YOUR VILLAGE OUT
CONGRATULATIONS.
WHO WE DO NOT HAVE AN AUTHOR
YET SO?
CAN I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CLAYPOOL.
TO HAVE A SECOND.
I BECAUSE THAT.
ALRIGHT.
VOCAL PLEASE.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE CH치VEZ.
DALY AYE AYE DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SOLACE.
SO IS AYE SEVEN ZERO RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE. CURRY
YOU ARE UP.
WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
WILL DIRECTLY REINVEST REVENUE
GENERATED FROM STAFF HOUSING
RENT AT THE YACHT BILL VETERANS
HOME. INTO MAINTAINING THE HOME.
NOT BILL VETERANS HOME IS MORE
THAN A CENTURY OLD. SO IT IS NOT
SURPRISING THAT THE FACILITIES
USED BY VETERANS AND STAFF.
RICART REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
UPGRADES.
LAST YEAR STAFF HOUSING GENERATE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE STATE
TO I CAN I JUST ASK ALL THE
MEMBERS TO LOWER THEIR VOICE IS
A LITTLE BECAUSE I CAN HARDLY
HEAR THE SPEAKER.
THE CIVIC EYELASHES STEP
HOUSING GENERATED MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE GENERAL
FUND.
ALTHOUGH THIS MONEY IS REQUIRED
TO GO BACK TO THE VETERANS IT IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER OR NOT THE
BUDGET ARGUMENTATION IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THE
REVENUE GENERATED FROM STAFF
HOUSING UP BEYOND THAT YOU DON'T
BILL IS DIRECTLY RETURNED TO THE
CAMPUS TO HELP CHIP AWAY AT THE
BACKLOG. OF MAINTENANCE ISSUES
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
NOT A COMPLETE SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THIS BACKLOG. BUT IT
WILL RESULT IN IMPROVEMENTS AT
YON FILL TO BENEFIT THE FORMER
SERVICE MEMBERS AND STAFF THERE.
FOR THIS REASONS AS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. OUR RIGHTS
SPEAKERS INSPIRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE HOME THEY'RE NOT
BILL IS A HUGE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND WHAT THE BILL
SETS FORWARD JUST REINVEST IN
THE HOUSING THERE THERE'S A
HOUSING SHORTAGE ALREADY IN NAPA
THE FIRES EXACERBATED IT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT TOOL. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AYE AND NAPA TO TO
PRESERVE THAT THE THE.
HOME THERE AND TO CONTINUE
INVESTING AND THE VETERANS THAT
LIVE THERE AND MAKE NAPA COUNTY
THEIR HOME HAS CREATE ABOUT THE
QUEUE. ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SPORT.
GOVERNMENT.
SEC THREE BRIEF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CORRECTIONS ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AS WELL AS
AMERICAN GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN DAWN HARPER
WITH AMERICAN LEGION WHATEVER
MONIES RAISED AN EYEBROW SHOULD
STAY YOUNG BILL SO HUNDRED
THOUSAND LEGIONNAIRES AGREE WITH
THIS I HOPE YOU'LL BE WITH US
WITH US AS WELL THANK YOU.
LARA GREECE REPRESENTING
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
LORRAINE PLASS WITH AMERICAN
VETERANS STATE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR
WE SUPPORT THIS.
VERY GOOD AND THE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL MISTER
FRAZIER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FANTASTIC BILL THANK YOU FOR THE
STUNT STARTING PROCESS WAS THE
BACKLOG. OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON OH YELP HELP.
OUT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW THEM AMOUNT
LET'S JUST PUT THE SO WHAT
REALLY CAME TO MIND IS WHEN WE
WERE THERE VISITING. AND THERE'S
A A NOTE ON THE WATER FAUCET THE
SAYS LET THE WATER RUN FIVE
MINUTES BEFORE DRINKING.
THE OTHER WAS AN EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR OLD GENTLEMAN WHO DIDN'T
HAVE HEAT IN HIS APARTMENT.
AND THAT IS ABSOLUTELY UNCALLED
FOR THERE'S SO MUCH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT WHY THIS MONEY
HAS ME RETURNED. A WE NEED TO
DO.
INVESTIGATE WHAT THE HAS BEEN
HAPPENING WITH THAT HUNTER FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS COOLEY
START WITH SOME BASIC
MAINTENANCE SUMMERS UPON US THEY
NEED TO BE WITH HIM AND NEW AIR
CONDITIONING UNITS.
RUNNING WATER I MEAN IT IT CAN
GO ON AND ON IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
FACILITY WHICH WE TREASURE IT IN
OF NAPA COUNTY. AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL AGREE WITH US.
NO ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND. IS A LIST OF ITEMS
THAT NEED TO BE REPAIRED.
TO BE ABLE TO RESPECT OUR
VETERANS AND YOU DON'T FEEL AND
THEIR CARE. AND THAT WE HAVE AN
OBJECTIVE AS AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO TO SUPPORT.
THE NEED THROUGH THE BUDGET OR
ONE OF THEIR OTHER WHATEVER
PROCESS WE CAN. CAN COME TO.
SO THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAVEZ. YES.
I GREW TO PLACE DEFTLY KNEES LA
TO HELP CLOSELY IF YOU LOOK AT
THE.
EVER STRUCTURE THERE'S A STUDY
DONE.
.
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
ON THE NEED JUSTIN CLIMBING IN
SEWERS AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THE. PLACE NEEDS WORK AND MANY
OF SELL THESE AS FAR AS THE
ROOMS THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IN A
ROOM. DOESN'T MEET NEARLY TO
STANDARD WE HAVE A SAY IN LAS
ANGELES OF THE DEFTLY NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT NEEDS.
MIKE MY BIG CONCERN IS ALWAYS.
THAT THE.
GIVEN THE FULL AUTHORITY TO
JANVIER IS THERE IS THERE ANY
OVERSIGHT OR THE ABILITY OF THE
SECRETARY TO.
.
BALLOT SAID ON THIS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THERE THAT WASN'T THERE WAS
A INVESTIGATION AND AUDIT. ON
THE ADMINISTRATORS OF YACHT BILL
BEFORE. BECAUSE OF.
AND ELIOT MAGISTRATE IS THERE.
ARE WONDERFUL PEOPLE BUT THEY'RE
THERE FOR MEDICAL CARE.
THEY'RE NOT REALLY THERE FOR.
.
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE.
AND.
AND ORIGINALLY ONE YACHT DOES
ESTABLISHING EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS
WAS SEEN AS THIS COMMAND
ELEMENT.
BUT WE STATUS ARE GONE FORWARD.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATOR YOM WILL
GET THE SAME AS ADMINISTRATOR
AND BEEN TERM TAKES CARE OF A
COUPLE HUNDRED VETERANS.
AND SO CLEARLY THAT THE PAY
STRUCTURE IS DIFFERENT.
I MEAN THE REQUIREMENT OVERSIGHT
DIFFERENT BUT THE PAY STRUCTURES
SAME AND THE SKILL LEVELS COMING
IN AT A YACHT BILL COULD BE THE
ONE TO SAME SKILL LEVEL
INVENTOR.
WHICH IS A NEW FACILITY SO.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERSIGHT DEBT
REALLY WOULD PUT SOME
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE SECRETARY.
SO HOW DID HOUSES SECRETARY.
DISALLOWED THE SECRETARY AND HIS
STAFF TO.
AND SURE THAT WE SPEND THE MONEY
WISELY.
I DO KNOW THAT THEY JUST
RECENTLY HIRED A GENTLEMAN THIS
CAN BE WORKING ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT THE SITE I'M I THINK THAT'S
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS NUMEROUS
COMMITTEE MEETINGS UP AT THE.
AT THE SITE.
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT'S OUR
NEXT STEP SHOULD BE. AND THERE'S
BEEN A MASTER PLAN THAT'S BEEN
OUT THERE.
THERE'S BEEN SOME FUNDING
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO GO THROUGH A
NEW. FACILITY.
WE HAVE.
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE THERE THAT%
SHOULD BE CITY LIVING IN SINGLE
BEDROOMS NOT HAVING TO SHARE
WITH OTHERS. SO THERE'S A LOT TO
GO ON OF ITS NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF THEIR.
I'M WORKING ALSO WITH
CONGRESSMAN THOMPSON ON THIS AND
SENATOR DODD. AS WELL AS A A
LOCAL SUPERVISORS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PLACE STAYS NAPA COUNTY. THAT
OUR RESIDENTS GET THE BEST OF
CARE. AND.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO ME IS
THAT.
WE'VE HAD A TOUGH TIME UP THERE
RECENTLY AND I THINK WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO GET THIS PLACE
BACK ON HIS FEET.
IT IS A GEM FOR A NAPA COUNTY
IN AS WELL AS FOR THE RESIDENTS
THAT LIVE THERE. THE STAFF NEEDS
A STATE SAFE PLACE TO WORK AND
RIGHT NOW I QUESTION IF THEY'RE
REALLY SAFE AS WELL.
AND I SCREWED IT ALL THAT BUT
I'M READING YOUR BILL THIS IS
ALL REVENUE GENERATED FROM PLOY
HOUSING ON THE CAMPUS. OF THE
VETERAN HOME OF YOUNG MALES
SHALL BE DEPOSITED. IN A FUND.
MAINTAINED BY THE ADMINISTRATOR
THE HOME.
AND THAT'S WHY I HAVE A CONCERN
BECAUSE.
WE HAD A PROBLEM WITH THAT
BEFORE AND I HAVE KIDS.
YEAH AND I HAVE A CONCERN OVER
THAT.
SO THAT I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
YOU SAID UNDER THE SENATE VERY
WELL I'M JUST LOOKING AT THE
OVERSIGHT ISSUE.
AND I WOULD I AGREE WITH HIM
LET'S WORK ON SOMETHING WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ADD THAT TO THE BILL.
SURE WE'RE REALLY RIGHT ON THE
MONEY WHERE IS THAT GOING TO HOW
WE CAN MAKE SURE GETS DISPERSED.
AND SEE HOW IT GOES BUT I AM I
AGREE WITH YOU.
EXECUTIVE MAYBE AMEND THAT ONE
COMPONENT BRING IN THE SECRETARY
TO GIVE THEM.
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT THAT AS I
SAID SAID THE MINISTRY OF THE
HOMES A WONDERFUL PERSON BUT TO
THEIR FOR MEDICAL REASONS.
NOT FOR ENGINEERING AND YOU KNOW
WAYS MANAGER AND AND.
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT.
AND YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO BE
YOU WANT THEM TO TAKE CARE OF
THE VETERAN SO.
I JUST THINK THAT ONE LINE NEEDS
TO BE ADJUSTED NOW TO BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE IF THAT WAS JUST.
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH HIM ON THAT ABSOLUTELY.
I AGREE.
WHAT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER?
COMES FROM THE PANEL.
I'M SORRY TO BE SO LONG WINDED
TODAY BUT DO AFTER TOURING THE
FACILITY IN AGAIN YOU MENTIONED
HOW PEOPLE ARE DOUBLED UP HAVE
ACTUALLY SEEN BETTER DORM ROOMS
IN UC'S AND I HAVE FOR THE FOR
VETERANS.
YOU KNOW IT AND AGAIN IT ALMOST
WORKED IS REMINISCENT OF SOME OF
THE OLD JAILS.
HOW WE WE STACK THEM LIKE CORD
WOOD I THINK THAT WITH EIGHT
THEY DESERVE BETTER? AND.
SO I THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CONCENTRATION ALSO HOW WE
CAN.
CHANGE THAT THAT CULTURE OF US
STACKING PEOPLE UP IN AND GIVING
THEM THE RESPECT THEY DESERVE.
ONE IDEA TO CHANGE A CULTURE I
THINK WE ALSO HAVE TODAY IN
IDENTIFIES THAT THERE'S A NEW
GROUP OF.
OFFICE.
SOLDIERS COMING IN ARE. COMING
VETERANS ARE COMING BACK.
AND THERE A LOT MORE WOMEN.
AND THERE'S A LOT MORE
DIFFERENT.
NEEDS THAT THEY NEED PTSD I'M
IS A LOT DIFFERENT NOT THAT IT
WASN'T BEFORE BUT WE IT'S NOT
AGING COMMUNITY. AND THAT WE
NEED TO PUT IN REALIZE WE'RE
GOING TO PUT OUR NEW VETERANS.
AND MAKE SURE THEY GET THE
ATTENTION THAT THEY DESERVE AS
WELL.
RIGHT DO WE HAVE MOTION.
SECOND.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER IN THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IRWIN. I'VE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE CHAVEZ.
CH치VEZ NOT VOTING DAILY. DALY
AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I HAVE MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SOLACE.
SOLIS AYE.
EIGHT ZERO.
ALRIGHT AND THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS AND OF FOR OUR
LAST BILL WE WILL CALL UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. THANK
YOU.
THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO.
STATE SPONSORED EDUCATION
BENEFIT CURRENTLY AFFORDED TO
MEMBERS.
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
SET TO SUNSET AND TWENTY
NINETEEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO WILL
RE AUTHORIZES CRUCIAL PROGRAM.
AND RICANS
CONSTITUENT AS THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT GI BILL.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE
NEEDED PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL BENEFIT CALIFORNIA'S
SERVICE MEMBERS FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME.
THE CURRENT PROGRAM PROVIDES
EDUCATIONAL GRANTS OF UP TO ONE
THOUSAND SUB SERVICE MEMBERS IN
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD.
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE MILITARY
RESERVE. TO ACHIEVE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
SHOULD THE SUNSET DATE NOT BE
REMOVED AND THE PROGRAM IS
ELIMINATED CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
THE ONE THE ONLY STATES IN THIS
NOT PROVIDE ANY SORT. OF STATE
SPONSORED EDUCATION BENEFITS
TO THAN TO THEIR NATIONAL GUARD.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
EXPANDS CURRENT PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY AND HELPS ENSURE
CALIFORNIA. ATTRACT AND RETAIN
HIGH QUALITY SERVICE MEMBERS
YOU SUPPORT THE STATE BY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FOR WILDFIRES FLOODS.
EARTHQUAKES AND SEARCH AND
RESCUE MISSIONS.
WITH ME IS CURRENT ALL DARREN
BENDER DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS.
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT WHO IS HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND.
IS THERE ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
I. HAVE THREE BREED GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
VETERANS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
JOHN HARPER THE AMERICAN LEGION
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE DO
SO THANK YOU.
LARA GREECE REPRESENTING
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. MUCH
NEEDED.
THE RAIN POSSUM MARIKA VETERANS
AND RECIPIENT OF A PRIOR
NATIONAL GUARD. ATTA.
IN DAMAGE.
WE SUPPORT THIS.
TING GOTHAM VIETNAM BIRDS
AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
COLONEL BUDGET LIKE THOSE BEACON
SUPPORT.
I'M JUST HERE TO.
THE ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
BUT I'LL JUST SAY THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ESTATES.
STATE BENEFIT THAT THE MEMBERS
OF OUR THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT
GET IT'S A CRUCIAL.
THAT IT CONTINUE AND I'D LIKE
TO.
THANK GOD MR MEDINA FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL AND.
GET ANY QUESTIONS I BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER.
IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
WHO?
YEAH.
OR ANY. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SURE.
SAME HERE I'M THERE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THE MOTION
IS DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS
IRWIN.
VOEPEL. AYE VOEPEL AYE CHAVEZ.
DALY. DALY AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER
AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA. SOLACE.
SOLACE I.
SIX ZERO.
GRAY WELL WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE.
THEY HAN. WORDS AREN'T.
NOT ADJOURNED.
YEAH I'M A ROOKIE WHAT YOU WANT.
YEAH RIGHT ROGER THAT SO WE'RE
NOT ADJOURN RELIEVING A ROLL
OPEN.
THAT OWNS.
THEY HAVE.
AMY EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE
OBERNOLTE.
GLORIA. GLORIA HIGH.
SOLACE
SO IF I.
THEY CONSENT CALENDAR IS AB TWO.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE IN S.
YOUR NINETY EIGHT.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I
.
SUCH.
OUR.
WEBER.
AND.
PAPON AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE
MURATSUCHI IN AYE MURATSUCHI
AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
MURATSUCHI AYE MURATSUCHI AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
MURATSUCHI. WERE CITY I AND THAT
CONSECUTIVE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I.
VOCAL.
AND I WISH I COULD.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT ON THE THIRD
FLOOR.
IS THERE ANY.
SOME COLONEL. AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THREE OBERNOLTE.
CH치VEZ I. KNOW I CAN THANK
CALENDAR THOMAS.
CH치VEZ I.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
MEDINA CHAVEZ.
CH치VEZ I.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN I
YEAR CURRY.
LOW.
GEN.
OKAY. YES I CAN I VOTE ON THEM
THIS RETAIN THIS BILL.
RIGHT NOW.
TODAY ON THE DEADLINE WITHOUT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
IRWIN.
IRWIN HIGH RIGHT.
ARE WE WAITING FOR ANY OTHER
MEMBERS.
SO IN.
SHE IS ACROSS THE HALLWAY.
SHE DID THINGS.
WELL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FOR OF
WEAKNESS QUIRK SILVA
.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA AYE. SO IS
THAT ALL MEMBERS YEAH ARE AYE.
THEN.
WE WILL ADJOURN THIS MEETING